y hacer el mayor ruido posible a favor
del apruebo el tren de la prueba y la
caravana de motoristas parte en su
recorrido en santiago en su campaña para
sumar más adeptos que el próximo 25 de
octubre voten por cambiar la actual
constitución porque queremos hacer un
llamado a toda la gente de la región
metropolitana y el resto de la región
del país que voten a prueba o convención
constitucional y nos ayuden a derrocar
una constitución pinochetista llena de
sangre que ha llenado de esa igualdad
todo este país los últimos 40 años los
votantes del rechazo también se hacen
presentes javier a escenas de una
plataforma de jóvenes llamada no gracias
que prefieren optar por reformar la
actual constitución de 1980 esta idea de
una nueva constitución nos estaban
vendiendo la pomada que en chile
significa un poco
no están vendiendo gato por liebre que
eso significa en definitiva de que nos
están prometiendo una cosa que en
definitiva no va a ser tal
javiera es una de las jóvenes que
aparece en la famosa franja electoral
que se repite dos veces en la televisión
durante los 28 días previos a la
elección y que juega un rol importante
en los indecisos en la prueba es
mayoritario en las encuestas y esto es
lo que nos cuenta la calle prueba
en el cual considero yo que debe haber
un cambio fundamental de raíces en el
sistema que no está gobernando
actualmente apruebo obviamente voy a
votar por el aprueba por a prueba
voy a votar rechazo porque creo que no
es una propuesta clara creo que
realmente el cambio de constitución fue
impulsado por grupos violentistas y creo
que porque es tirarse a la piscina sin
que haya agua adentro la nueva
constitución fue uno de los mayores
reclamos del estallido del 18 de octubre
del año pasado en el país
por eso la otra campaña se realiza en
los muros de las calles donde la prueba
también es mayoritario el domingo
sabremos si los chilenos deciden contar
por primera vez en sus más de dos siglos
de historia con una constitución elegida
por el pueblo
[Música]